can you see me properly can you talk to
me properly yeah for sure i can only
open my mouth so far but like this but
yeah i can see you of course in the name
of fashion why did you have to go with
this ensemble tonight darling um because
it's fabulous i love richard quinn and i
love kind of the
sex with the
cross
i feel like it makes a statement
and uh
yeah also like
i feel like a lot of stuff has been
happening to sex workers and people
you know taking on platforms and stuff
and they're necessary and
yeah i don't know
it's like a little good a little evil
yeah like that's kind of the thing like
the
religious stuff and then the
freaky stuff oh my how did you get that
on was that like oh my god some jelly
stuff no it's like baby powder and then
you like you baby powder your entire
body and then you like slip it all over
my god
it was so fun i loved it oh wow well i
gotta ask you some big news is buzzing
around this carpet tonight britney
spears is engaged oh my god what do you
make of that news that makes me so happy
i just i just want her to be so so happy
uh i feel like everything that's been
happening to her is really awful to see
and like i think
like i just want to see her happy
because i'm such a huge fan i think
she's so talented such a superstar she
deserves to be happy so it's great yeah
and you turned to brittany to help you
get acclimated with life here in the u.s
and if i'm not mistaken didn't you
reference her and in watching videos and
things oh yeah i mean i was just a stan
and i was watching videos of hers to
learn english with subtitles because mtv
germany you can uh put on that they
always have subtitles and with english
so yeah i would like watch it on repeat
and learn what you were saying
pretty good right